Speaker 1: Republican Senator John Kennedy weighed
in on the debt ceiling debacle that's going on
right now. Negotiations, discussions, Republicans
wanting to leverage the debt ceiling to push for
spending cuts. Even those spending cuts should
happen when you're weighing spending, not weighing
fulfilling your financial obligations. All of that
has been discussed. But I want to take a look at
a moment with Republican Senator John Kennedy
appearing on Fox News and making a point about.
The debt and then we'll respond to it.
Very fascinating stuff here. Take a look.
Speaker 2: If you're going to have
a party, you have to pay the band.
If you're going to borrow money, you have to
pay it back. That's true as a moral principle
and a principle of practicality. And you
don't you don't have to be a senior at Cal
Tech to figure that out. Now, here's the
truth part. Congress had a spending party,
more specifically, the House Democrats, not the
House Republicans. The Senate Democrats and a
whole lot of Senate Republicans have a spending
party. I didn't vote to do it. I would have been
happy with a couple of beers after work.
Speaker 1: It's I don't know how that last
sentence connects to what he was saying, honestly.
Maybe I missed something, but let's just take this
as an opportunity to discuss this myth that
Democrats are the irresponsible spenders. They
run up the debt and the deficit. Republicans have
to go in there and clean up the mess. And you hear
it all the time. And I was actually hitting or
sitting, I should say, at a dinner last night with
a friend talking about how it's almost impressive
the Republicans, despite the facts not being on
their side, have convinced so many people that
they are better for the economy, which we know
not true, and are more financially responsible for
spending. They don't run up the deficit as much.
And let's just go through a few pieces I've come
across over time that kind of illustrates this
is not the case. As this New York Times op ed
writes, The Democrats juiced the economy by
spending money and then leave Republicans to clean
up the mess. Over the last four decades. In fact,
Republican presidents have run up larger deficits
than Democrats. Another piece here from Towards
data science. While Republicans often claim that
they are the more fiscally responsible party,
my research suggests otherwise. Compared to
Democratic presidents, Republicans are estimated
to add between 0.75% and 1.2% more to the deficit
as a percent of GDP each year. They are in office
and they will look at one final chart here that
shows you the deficit change, whether up or down
over time. And of course, the reason why we're
speaking in terms of deficit is when you're
looking at fiscal year after fiscal year, one
president will come into power and we refer to
the presidential party who's in the White House,
because that's the easiest to understand. Congress
could be any which way. But at the end of the day,
things have to get signed off for the most part
by the president, and he kind of holds authority
over his party through that process. And so we
can measure it that way. And what we see is
actually Republicans, as this chart shows,
have jacked up the deficit. Democrats have often
decreased it. And because Biden's presidency is
only halfway through, we don't have a whole
lot of information to share on that yet. But.
As I was saying, the reason why we talk in terms
of deficit is the debt is just accumulating. It's
just on and on and on and on. It gets bigger
and bigger. And so saying that this president
was president when the debt was at
its largest is kind of pointless
because even if they got in office
and the debt increased one penny then.
They would have the largest debt in American
history. That's not really valuable, whereas the
deficit is understanding how much of the budget is
spending beyond what's being brought in in taxes.
Right. So that's how much each year is being
spent beyond what the government is actually
bringing in, in taxes. And that's where you can
understand, is a Democrat decreasing that deficit
and bringing down how much more we're spending
or are they increasing? And often Republicans
are actually doing that. More are actually
increasing the deficit, more contributing than
compared to GB and compared to their time as
president. More to that scary big number that the
Republican Party likes to fearmonger a lot about.
So John Kennedy there, that that's just giving you
a historical context because we hear that talking
points so often. And if you're in interpersonal
conversations where it comes up that Republicans
are better for the economy and they're better for
the debt or whatever it might be, we just
understand that's not factual. And even
especially with the economy example, as you
dive into more and more specific bits of data,
you realize how much of a trend this is that under
Democratic presidents, even if you control for
Congress and different times based on crises,
still democratic processes are better for the
economy. And then we're looking here better
for the deficit. So these branding items that
Republicans have been able to use so effectively
are so often just so dishonest. And so right
there, John Kennedy honestly should just think
of more about his own party, because clearly,
historically, Democrats aren't the ones with
the problem. Find me on Twitter. Luke P Beasley